[موسيقى]
الشمس البرتقالي نزعتم يوما سنه والشمس
البرتقالي نزعت يوما سنه انا
انا يا كريم يا رب
والشمس البرتقالي نزعتم يوما سنه والشمس
البرتقاله لنزعت يوما سنه كنت يوما صغير
لا كنت كبير ملات جيوبي حلوى ملونه كثيره
كنت يوما صغيرا لا لا كنت كبير بدات جيوب
حلوى ملونه كثيره اخذ من ذاك الجيب وقرقش
اصدر
جلابه كنتم فخورا وفجاه عضتني الحلوى صلب
اسقطت هنالك سنه انا انا
والشمس البرتقال لنزعت يوم السنه والشمس
البرتقال لنزعت يوما سنه كنت قديما فتيا
عضلات قويه امشي واهز الارض لاسنان
العاجيه كنت قديما فتيا عضلات قويه امشي
واهز الارض لاسنان عجي وفي يوم مطير نازلت
من سريري وفي يوم مطير نازلت
من سارك هل هو
انا
انا والشمس البرتقال نزعت يوما سنه والشمس
البرتقال نزعت يوما سنه
[موسيقى]